au son des prières depuis quatre jours
ils sont des milliers à venir se
recueillir dans ce parc du centre ville
pour déposer une fleur et prendre le
temps de saluer la mémoire de toutes ces
jeunes vies perdues parmi eux l as in
our et 12 ans
[Musique]
il veut étudier devenir dentiste il ne
veut surtout pas mourir sous les balles
à l'école ces solutions davantage de
contrôle sur les armes à feu et plus de
sécurité
nous avons besoin de gars de devant nos
écoles dit-elle pour que les enfants se
sentent en sécurité
troublée par le carnage de la fusillade
cindy elle est encore sous le choc
posez est venu avec sa famille pour
témoigner sa compassion aux familles des
victimes il se pose de sérieuses
questions sur l'inefficacité de
l'intervention policière de mardi
dernier
voilà que depuis que la police a reconnu
avoir eu tort de retarder l'intervention
pour neutraliser le tueur de 18 ans la
population de uralde et en a gros sur le
coeur
ils ont attendu trop longtemps croire
andy soares des vies auraient pu être
sauvées
andrade est malade elle
les apprécie que la police ait reconnu
avoir mal géré la situation
et elle estime que les résidents sont en
droit de savoir ce qui s'est réellement
passé jara tomassi un vétéran de l'armée
reste encore plus conciliant
il va falloir tirer les leçons de cette
tragédie dit il allons nous enfin air de
loire est-ce qu'ils ne sortent il ne
pense pas qu'une autre loi pour élargir
le contrôle des armes à feu soit la
solution
face à cet état d'esprit on en viendrait
presque à oublier que les états unis
comptent environ 330 millions de
personnes et que selon les plus récents
chiffres il y aurait près de 400
millions d'armes à feu civile en
circulation ici frédéric arnould
radio-canada où valcke